(happy electronic music)
- Gonna lift up the top card.
This is your card, remember this card?
- Stop.
- Right there, where you said
stop was where your card was.
- Wait, what?
- I'm learning more stuff,
it's like, it's basically like magic
because like you start off here and then
at some point, when you don't expect it,
you'll get to another level.
- Get mine, where do I get mine?
(kids mumble)
- There's constantly something going on.
Always busy, always noise.
- I walk away with the pink one.
- Any mom who is raising
her kids alone is worried
that their kids are gonna fall behind
or not have enough of something to reach
where they should in life as they grow.
- There was like some
things actually like,
in third grade that I
went back and relearned
and it actually helped me
a lot in the sixth grade.
One thing that really helped me
is where if you can't get it,
you can get a hint or watch the videos.
- When he's using the Khan Academy,
he tells me that he gets
to watch his progress
so he gets to see each step that he takes,
how far he's getting in it,
and that makes him motivated to keep going
and to get to the next level.
And it's like instant
gratification for him.
(Sean mumbles)
- Oh.
- That was the second one.
- I am taking control of his learning
and just seeing his success,
it gives him his own boost of confidence.
Not just in the classroom, but at home.
I'm extremely proud,
just seeing the little
person he's growing into
and the pride he has in himself
always makes me feel good
'cause then I feel like
I'm doing something right
as a parent.
- Need help?
I really like helping a lot.
Besides math and learning and all that,
that's one of my favorite things to do.